yo come to this video char pochu okay um
yeah let's go d 5 i'm close to
completing this weekend next week will
be a new yeah a new thing is themed week
so i'd rather go a couple of e 40 5s
again before i have to play something
entirely different next week okay um i
played the Berlin for a change and yeah
he played Bishop c6 not the most
ambitious way to do it hmm okay he's
going for d4 here interesting let's go
on okie 8d fired it doesn't look
entirely logical yeah with her giving up
the bishop and then yeah it seems like
he's trying to open up the whole thing
maybe i'm wrong though no he placed 93
Jenna night she was coming and Bishop e6
doesn't look look to grade is C sixsome
so that i can go to c7 maybe but unsure
him 983 was interesting okay now he's
switching back to this kind of setup
let's prevent Bishop g5 I need to be
ready for bishops e7f Eagles night c4 so
that's that's what happened okay so who
interesting
see going for a four a five yeah maybe I
wonder if Bishop a 6am off let's let's
try that your Knight takes e4 is a
possible idea and it seems he he I
thought that this isn't it threat I
wasn't totally sure of it ok so maybe 27
or 28 now a5 is an interesting move but
I think b5 should be ok ok so let me
centralized so now a 5 is not coming
anymore that's good next thing I should
think about is what about this night
damn can I improve it night two to e 62
f 4 would be good yeah he might go d 4
at some point but my queen yeah yeah
this is this is interesting that's
interesting so it's a double edged thing
why does opening up the position which
it's not the greatest idea against the
bishop air but I have a I don't have a
particularly well coordinated and peace
position here it takes with the rook wow
that's a that's surprising I thought
night takes would be good okay
interesting I did not think about that
move at all so let's go here I mean he
has to show something concrete yeah
otherwise you know of this now I just
have to bishops for nothing
hmm yeah where's the point I know my dad
I want to have a passer at the end there
under on the queenside or is it going
before some kind of thing no ok so I'm
going back I checking this pawn and now
night g6 maybe I wonder if before is a
move maybe get out of this just to make
sure it's not happening Wow ok hmm yeah
I don't know taking wha let's just if I
take it if you might take with the pawn
but ok that's it's also not not really
great
so we've got two bishops and the
potential tassel on the queenside just
have to get this passer in the first
place and it seemed just this is not bad
we should come see a possibility to see
three okay so if i go to see three let's
start with that threatens to win the e4
pawn okay so over here okay you might
have this Nazi aid so let's go here keep
an eye on c4
interesting
maybe just King you seven next okay
let's go here I can check on on f5 but
with this 1i thought I can take and play
97 in that case just to grab the pawn
how is he not losing the power now check
the ship 1c three covers g7 and this
should trade trade the nitride you for
hangs
yep time morning ship before I could
have played Bishop before maybe I should
have done that but two connected passers
was pretty good yeah the two points they
win on their own basically should be 5 C
3 and so on want this one
yeah got enough time him we should have
four made not almost no made I but beat
you check and then Bishop made let's
check mates also made yeah I think he he
really underestimated this end game he
just basically am yeah voluntarily
traded it down to a good end game in
this position well I have the two
bishops and you if you go for deform
which I don't don't necessarily think is
bad you have to yeah you have to justify
it with concrete play and I thought
night XD for would be pretty interesting
because I'm a bit awkward here on the
seven yeah I thought I thought c5 is
probably my move here and c6 hangs then
this and probably something like this
and that that cannot be bad for white I
mean at least if he really has no better
idea he can take on c7 and make sure
that I don't have the bishop anymore
taking that I don't know I think I can
take any form yeah that should be okay
but he went here and after that i'm
really just better because he has no
nothing to show for the pair of bishops
and well which rated that a five yeah
that's actually also questionable
because that makes makes it easier for
me to UM to get a passport but okay
Bishop here and now night c4 yeah we
should be 782 jumped this is just pretty
substantial advantage for black to
bishops without any anything to show for
it for white I know he even traded
Queens so that was strange from he had
some
with good technical play black should
probably win this here yeah also those
those are our week now in here 9 p-5
year 95 I can take and play 97 and win
he probably has to get here but this is
again how is he covering sorry how is he
again covering that this when I keep the
bishop on the nights are not doing much
they're pretty much dominated by the
bishops and if he keeps it I mean I have
a very quick passer here and my king is
more active this is also potentially
week just very nice for black interior
the pawn is dropping check I don't know
he traded very much voluntarily into
that bad end game if you take on c6 this
is a really young scenario you want to
avoid I mean here this is reasonably
solid I mean what cannot expect much it
this kind of setup own it's not very
active but you shouldn't be much worse
and I think the way you played it was
good actually just has to take with the
noid that makes sense because well I
lost lost a bit of time here with this
potential regrouping and this is fairly
fairly logical using this this weekend
phone on c6 this is this is about equal
I guess ok well thanks for watching